Hello guys, welcome back to yeagerists,
In today's video we will be going
through the story of Falco Grice.
Leave a like on this video and subscribe to our
channel if you want to see more content like this.
During the Marleyan war with the Mid-East
Allied Forces, Falco is present among other
Eldians fighting on behalf of Marley. However,
he and some of his friends such as Udo, Zofia,
and Gabi are valued as Warrior candidates with
the potential to inherit the Armored Titan power.
During the fight, Falco and some of
his comrades are hit by enemy fire,
killing some but sparing Falco and leaving him
wounded. His brother Colt Grice appears to save
him and puts his hard hat on Falco's head before
carrying him on his back while avoiding enemy
fire. When Colt returns to the hiding trench with
his wounded brother, their fellow candidates tend
to his wounds as Gabi re-explains their objective.
When Udo begins to panic in fear of their military
failing, he wraps Falco's bandages too tightly
and Gabi scolds him. Falco then wonders why they
are on the front lines as candidates and Gabi
explains that it is so they can be evaluated
by Commander Magath for their capabilities
as successors to the Armored Titan power.
When Zofia begins to boast about her grades, Gabi
interrupts her by explaining her superiority above
all the other candidates. When Gabi offers to
take out the enemies' anti-Titan artillery solo,
Falco shows serious concern for her
safety and fears that she will be hurt.
He watches her execute her plan of attack and
once Gabi is successful in derailing the train,
she begins to flee only to be shot
at by one final surviving gunman.
This pushes Falco over the edge and he jumps
out of the trench to try to save her. However,
an ally named Porco Galliard transforms
into a Titan and shields Gabi from gunfire
while she and Falco collide as they both
dive for the ditch. Falco looks on in awe
as the Titan stands above him and he watches as
Galliard races off and kills the last gunman.
After returning to the trench, Falco brings a
wounded enemy soldier in order to heal his wounds.
Although some of his companions, such as Udo,
help him, his superior and Gabi mock him,
stating that he is a weird person and that there
is no way he will earn the power of the Armored
Titan by fighting like that. After Udo translates
what the foreigner said, Falco seems surprised at
being insulted. Falco contemplates the
airborne attack against Fort Slava and
seems very shocked by witnessing Titans eating
soldiers and Reiner's defeat against the Armada.
After the battle, Falco is resting on the
docks with his friends. They all seem worried,
talking about how Titans may no longer be the main
force of the world. Falco tries to reassure Gabi,
telling her that Reiner has survived losing
several limbs and even his head. After they
see traumatized war prisoners and Udo gets angry
because of the harm done to the Eldian reputation,
Reiner arrives and is coldly saluted by Falco.
After Falco suggests Reiner should rest, Gabi
angrily replies that he should be the one resting.
Sometime later, Falco is inside a train heading
towards their homeland. In their wagon, Colt gets
drunk and starts praising Gabi along with many
other soldiers. Falco states how his brother gets
very emotional whenever he drinks. He tells Reiner
bitterly how Reiner only has two years left before
dying and, if Gabi inherits the Armored Titan
she will only live to be twenty-seven.[22]
After accusing Reiner of not caring about her,
the sudden and incriminatory reply of the older
Warrior scares Falco. The boy proceeds to swear
his loyalty to Marley and states how honorable
it is to inherit the power of the Titans.
He finally states that he will be the
one to inherit the Armored Titan power.
Finally, Reiner tells him how he must surpass Gabi
in order to protect her from this cruel world.
After arriving in Liberio, their hometown, Falco
recalls how Reiner took full responsibility for
the failure of the Paradis Island Operation,
and wonders why Reiner risks his life and
power so many times. Reiner looks at
him and the boy suddenly looks away,
asking himself why Reiner told him to protect Gabi
and if the Warrior actually wanted the war to end.
When the soldiers enter the Internment Zone,
Falco and his brother are greeted by their
parents. They seem very worried, asking the
children about injuries and Colt's headache.
Falco then sees a group of
veteran Eldian soldiers,
many of them with notable injuries. Falco asks
Koslow about them, and he tells him that they have
no family and will be treated at the hospital.
The officer then imitates the sound of a bomb,
scaring the traumatized soldiers just for fun.
Falco decides to help calm down the soldiers
and tells them that they will not have to fight
any longer, as he fixes one soldier's armband.
Falco appears, stretching and exerting
himself whilst training at HQ, and states
to his fellow candidates that he will be
the one to eventually inherit the Armored
Titan. This angers Gabi into headbutting him,
yet still, he holds his conviction. Later on,
the two can be seen training together in a
violent manner whilst being overlooked by an
instructor. After training, his lack of natural
skill causes him to cry out in frustration,
unwittingly stopping Reiner from committing
suicide. He absent-mindedly walks towards a nearby
hospital, where the soldier whose armband he
adjusted, invites the boy to sit down next to him.
The man introduces himself as Mr. Kruger and
confides to Falco that he actually does not
suffer from mental trauma, unlike the other
soldiers in the hospital; he asks if Falco
will rat him out to the staff, which he denies.
Kruger asks Falco about his injuries and training,
who shares his grievances with him.
Reminding him of himself when he was younger,
Kruger encourages the boy to look
forward and have faith in his decisions.
Falco is later asked by Kruger to deliver a
letter for him, claiming that the letter is
to inform his family that he was safe and sound
inside the internment zone. Having developed
a sense of respect and admiration for the man,
Falco obliges with the request. One month later,
Falco has carried many letters as a favor to
Mr. Kruger, even though there was a risk of him
getting caught. He also surpasses Gabi in training
by beating her in a race and is commended by Udo,
Zofia, and the two officials at the Internment
Zone gate. Gabi expresses her frustration with
Falco's determination to beat her, pointing out
that his family will be made honorary Marleyans
either way, once Falco's older brother inherits
the Beast Titan. Falco admits that he is trying
to outrank Gabi for her sake, which confuses
her and makes Falco run off in embarrassment.
He visits Mr. Kruger in the hospital, telling him
about his recent success and expressing gratitude
for motivating him. In return, Kruger thanks
him for delivering his letters for the last
month, and informs the boy that he will
be going back home after the festival,
causing Falco to sigh in dismay. He leaves when
he notices a doctor approaching their bench.
On the eve of the festival, Falco and the other
candidates are assigned to serve the visiting
ambassadors from the countries allied with Marley.
He observes Udo accidentally spill some wine on
one of the ambassadors and goes over to check
on him; after the ambassador leaves and takes
the blame for the incident, they all wonder how
she knew they were Eldians and her reasons why
she saved Udo from almost certain death. On the
same day Willy Tybur is to announce his decision
regarding Paradis Island, Falco and the other
Warrior candidates enjoy the festival with Reiner.
Shortly before the announcement,
Falco encounters Kruger again;
Kruger mentions to Falco that he was friends
with Reiner and asks Falco to find him,
wishing to see Reiner before he leaves back
home. Falco tracks down Reiner and finds him
seated with the other Warriors. He calls
Reiner and leads him to Kruger's location.
Sensing the irregularity of the situation and
Reiner's shocked expression, Falco originally
puts the tension down to the two men not having
seen each other in years; however, he quickly
realizes something is wrong after seeing
Reiner fearfully obey Kruger's order to sit.
Falco goes to see himself out but he is instructed
to stay by both Kruger and Reiner. Falco stays
and listens to Lord Tybur's presentation
from inside the cellar. During a break,
Falco rationalizes that Mr. Kruger must have known
Reiner from his time on Paradis Island, deeply
unsettling him. At the apex of Tybur's speech, he
realizes that Kruger is actually the Eldian rebel,
Eren Yeager. As Eren begins to regenerate his
missing leg, Falco accuses Eren of tricking him,
causing Eren to apologize for the deceit. Falco
realizes that the letters he had delivered made
him complicit, and demands to know where they
went. When Eren tells him they were for his
comrades stationed in Marley, Falco falls to the
floor in guilt. With Willy Tybur's speech ongoing,
Eren proclaims that Tybur is right; he is the
bad guy. He begins a conversation with Reiner
while Falco listens intently. As Eren is talking
about his experiences in Marley, he turns to Falco
and says that past the oceans and inside the
Walls, people are all the same; there are good
people like him, and those who are wicked and act
selfishly for themselves. He listens as the two
continue their conversation and is shocked when
Reiner ultimately breaks down in guilt, accepting
responsibility and regrets for his actions
against Eren and those living across the ocean.
As Eren offers his hand to help Reiner stand,
Falco begins to process everything he just
heard when he sees Reiner quickly turn towards
him. As Eren transforms into the Attack Titan,
Falco is grabbed by Reiner to try and save him by
absorbing the resulting blast of energy. Thanks to
Reiner's partial transformation into the Armored
Titan, Falco emerges unscathed from the ruins of
the building that he, Eren Yeager, and Reiner
Braun were just in. He looks around in horror
at the fighting and destruction around him and
notices Eren's Attack Titan trapped inside the
web formed by the War Hammer Titan. He is still in
disbelief that Eren deceived him and then wonders
how he managed to survive. Remembering that Reiner
bit his hand to transform, Falco turns around and
searches for Reiner in the incomplete body of his
Titan. He finds Reiner unconscious and apologizes
for leading him into a trap. Falco wonders
why Reiner has not recovered from the blast,
but then recalls his behavior before transforming
and realizes why Reiner has not begun to heal:
someone with the Power of the Titans needs to
have a strong will to live in order to regenerate
quickly and Reiner has seemingly lost his. Before
leaving to go find help, Falco reassures Reiner
that he still has allies including himself
and Reiner's younger cousin, Gabi. While
searching for help, Falco is astonished at
Zeke Yeager's prowess with the Beast Titan.
Magath finds Falco and demands to know what he
is doing and if he is hurt. Falco tells him that
Reiner is stuck in the ground and it is all his
fault. Meanwhile, Gabi arrives with a rifle. In
the distance they see an enormous explosion
coming from the port, after Magath says that
it's the Colossus Titan's transformation, they try
to run only to be knocked down by the shock wave.
As the Warriors continue fighting with the
Survey Corps, Levi Ackerman defeats the Beast
Titan in front of Falco and the others and
seems to kill Zeke right in front of them.
Also, a victim of the fighting, Pieck's Cart Titan
tumbles off the roof and crashes to the street
behind Falco, Gabi, and Magath. As Jean Kirstein
gets ready to deliver the finishing blow to Pieck,
Falco rushes to her side
and begs him not to shoot.
Despite Falco's pleas, Jean shoots a
Thunder Spear at the Cart Titan; however,
a burst of steam released from the Titan's
wound hits him, partially hitting Falco as well,
and the spear explodes on the ground instead.
A severely injured Pieck emerges from the Cart
Titan into Falco's arms and is witnessed by the
Survey Corps coming off the roof of the building,
who quickly surge into the attack. However, they
are repelled by Magath and Marleyan soldiers,
with Magath commanding Gabi to help Falco. As
Marley's army continues fighting the Corps,
Magath covers Falco and Gabi who escape carrying
Pieck. Taking refuge inside a building, Falco and
Gabi are astonished by the state Pieck has been
left in. Falco observes that her injuries are so
serious that her body is not repairing itself
fast enough, and Gabi adds that the Cart Titan
is not as tough as some of the others, such as
the Armored Titan. Gabi asks Falco about Reiner,
and Falco responds that he does not know, as he
was below the building behind the stage during
Eren's attack, and he thinks that they should not
disturb him. Gabi is shocked at Falco's words,
reminding him that Udo, Zofia, and many others
have been killed by Eren. The conversation is
cut short after Gabi sees an airship coming
to Liberio to assist the Survey Corps.
The children soon witness the Attack Titan
defeating and trying to bite through the
nape of the Jaw Titan, which prompts them to yell
desperately for Reiner to save him. Their screams
are successful as Reiner surfaces in an un-armored
Titan form and manages to take Galliard away from
Eren, although he is knocked down by him. As Eren
comes out of his Titan form after running out of
strength and leaves the battle scene with Mikasa,
Gabi decides that she will not let them escape,
and takes a rifle as she runs out of the building
in their pursuit, while Falco tries to stop her.
As they are running, Falco is able to catch
up with Gabi and tells her that going after
them now would only get her killed just like Zofia
and Udo. Gabi explains that despite how they are
treated in the internment zone, it is still their
home and is incredulous as to why Falco would not
want them to fight back; Falco recalls Eren and
Reiner's discussion and says that they were only
responding to the initial attack done by Reiner
and the other Marley Warriors four years ago.
This does not convince Gabi and she picks up her
rifle again. As Gabi tells Falco to inform her
family that she fought to the end, she prepares
to fly up to the escaping airship using the
equipment from a dead Survey Corps soldier. After
remembering Reiner's plea for him to save Gabi,
Falco grabs on at the last minute and goes with
her. Entering the airship, Falco spots Gabi
shooting one of the soldiers. As she fires again,
Falco knocks Gabi aside and narrowly saves her
from getting shot by another soldier. Falco tries
to quiet Gabi down as she proclaims they are still
fighting and that the Paradis Island leaders
will pay for attacking them. The two are taken
away from the soldiers and are stunned to see
that Zeke, who was thought to be dead by Marley,
is still alive and was one of the coordinators
behind the attack on the internment zone.
After arriving at Paradis Island, Gabi
and Falco are escorted away by a member
of the Military Police and put into a prison cell.
Once imprisoned, Gabi begins having a seizure
in their cell; Falco tries to help her and the
guard enters the cell to check. However, Gabi
had been faking it and beats the guard in the
face with a brick hidden within her clothes.
Despite Falco's protests, she hits the guard
again and forces Falco to help her hide him. Gabi
flees the prison and Falco, unsure of what to do,
follows her.[55]After running all night, both
of them stop at a stream for water and to rest.
He notices that Gabi still has her armband on and
tells her to take it off before someone sees them.
As Gabi refuses, Falco forcibly takes
it off and gets thrown to the ground.
He is incredulous as to why Gabi is acting this
way and claims she has gone crazy. Just then,
a girl named Kaya comes by and asks what they are
doing. As the girl invites them to come with her
to her house nearby, Falco spots Gabi discreetly
picking up a rock to presumably attack her;
he then looks at Gabi and takes it
away as they proceed to follow her.
Falco and Gabi arrive at the house and Kaya
tells them to wait. Gabi contemplates taking
one of the horses, though Falco advises
they stay for a few days. Heading inside,
Falco tells Gabi that he will handle the talking.
He introduces himself and Gabi as "Ben" and "Mia"
and says that they are siblings who ran
away from home. As they have breakfast,
Falco sees Gabi swat away Lisa Blouse's hand; he
quickly apologizes for Gabi's behavior and coaxes
her to eat. Later that day, Falco is working
with Gabi in the stables. He reiterates that they
should stay where they are, expressing confidence
that either Colt or Reiner will come for them. He
goes with Gabi to have lunch outside and learns
they are staying at an orphanage for children
who lost their parents during the last four years.
As Falco and Gabi argue, they are surprised when
Kaya mentions that she knows they are from Marley;
Falco tries to come up with an excuse when he sees
Gabi inch closer to a pitchfork. She tries to stab
Kaya with it, but Falco wrestles it away. They are
led to Kaya's old village and learn that everyone
either ran away or was eaten by the Titan.
Falco is horrified and eventually confesses
that it was part of an experiment four years ago
and apologizes for Kaya's mother getting killed.
Gabi berates Falco for revealing that to her, but
he ignores it. He asks how Kaya managed to survive
and is stunned to hear that a girl brought over an
ax to fight the Titan, giving her enough time to
get away. Later on, Falco goes with Gabi and the
Blouse family to the restaurant where Niccolo is
working. When dinner is served, Falco is stunned
by how high the quality of food is and how he has
tasted nothing like it before in his life.[59]
He makes up an excuse to leave the table
and Gabi goes with him to find Niccolo.
They discover him in the basement and reveal their
true identities as Marleyan Warrior candidates.
Falco notices the fear and horror in Niccolo's
face when Gabi reveals she killed Sasha and
tries to get Gabi's attention. As Niccolo
attacks her, Falco dives in front and gets
knocked unconscious after being struck by a
wine bottle. The unconscious Falco is brought
by Niccolo into the room as the latter
reveals Falco's role in Sasha's death.
After the situation is cleared up, Niccolo
tells Hange to wash out Falco's mouth
before revealing the wine bottle was one
of many containing Zeke's spinal fluid.
Shortly after, Connie and Hange begin to rinse
Falco's mouth with water as Niccolo reveals
more information about Zeke's spinal fluid.
Falco is then taken to a separate room to bathe
but is interrupted when the Yeagerists arrive.
Falco later regains consciousness, and while
being taken to Shiganshina by the Yeagerists,
he experiences a sudden shot of electricity run
through him as a result of Zeke's scream from
the Titan Forest. Once arriving in Shiganshina,
Falco presumably learns of his condition and is
then separated from the rest of the group from
the restaurant and imprisoned with other Eldians
who have consumed Zeke's spinal fluid.[63] The
Marleyan forces arrive at Shiganshina and launch
their surprise attack to steal the Founding Titan.
On the prison's rooftop, Eren transforms into his
Titan form to face the Jaw Titan, while Falco
looks up in horror inside his prison cell, upon
hearing the commotion.[64] As many of the other
prisoners demand to be released, Nile Dok suggests
to Falco that the attack could be an attempt to
rescue him, but Falco is unconvinced. Nonetheless,
Nile encourages Falco to use the attack
as an opportunity to escape if he
can.[Soon, the prisoners are released by
the Survey Corps to help fight off Marley.
As he enters the battlefield, Falco
notices his brother and Gabi nearby
and Nile discretely delivers him,
ordering them to get out of harm's way.
As Falco takes refuge in a house with Gabi and
Colt, Falco reveals his unwitting role in the
attack on Liberio to them, lamenting that Udo
and Zofia died because of him. He also reveals
his feelings to Gabi, admitting that he joined
the Warrior program to give her the chance at
living a long and happy life with him.[67] Falco
remains in low spirits over his fate but agrees
with Colt that there is a chance Zeke might
not transform him and the others if he is made
aware that Falco ingested some of the spinal
fluid.[68]Falco and Colt manage to find Zeke
at the edge of Shiganshina and Colt begs Zeke not
to scream, informing him of Falco's predicament.
Gabi urges him to flee out of Zeke's range with
her but Falco tells her to stay back. Although
Zeke expresses remorse for Falco's situation,
the news does not stop him from screaming.
Falco tries to shove his brother aside but Colt
refuses to let go, proclaiming he will always be
with Falco. As he transforms into a Titan, Falco
is immediately ordered by Zeke to kill Reiner
and charges towards his commanding officer. Since
Reiner is preoccupied with trying to subdue Eren,
Falco's Pure Titan quickly gets the upper hand and
begins to bite through the armor covering Reiner's
nape. Before he can finish, Falco notices a
severely injured Galliard nearby stumbling
out of his Titan and devours him instead,
becoming the new inheritor of the Jaw Titan.
Falco's unconscious body is retrieved
from his Titan by Jean Kirstein.
After restraining Falco, Jean suggests feeding
Falco to one of the newly-transformed Pure Titans,
but Connie Springer is adamant that his
mother should be allowed to devour Falco.
An argument breaks out which results in
Connie kidnapping Falco and fleeing with him.
Falco wakes up on route to Ragako with no memory
of any of the events immediately preceding his
transformation. Connie claims to have found
him unconscious in Shiganshina and saved him.
He then says he will be taking Falco to a
hospital which will help with his memory
loss and although Falco is grateful, he is left
ill at ease by a feeling that he has met Connie
before. The two stop to rest overnight and Falco
overhears Connie talking to himself about Sasha.
When they arrive at Ragako, Falco
reveals that he knows where they are
and that he overheard Connie
talking during the night.
Connie states that he does not want revenge for
Sasha's death and shows Falco an immobilized
Titan in the village. Connie tells Falco that
he wants him to help him brush the Titan's teeth
and Falco agrees. Before they can start, they
are interrupted by the arrival of Gabi and Armin.
Falco is stunned to realize that
he has inherited the Jaw Titan
and does not resist as Connie begins
trying to forcibly feed him to the Titan.
He is only saved by Armin, who tries to feed
himself to the Titan, and Connie is forced to save
him. After being rescued from the Titan, Falco
learns of his brother's death and mourns for him.
The four return to Shiganshina, where
they run into Annie Leonhart while eating.
After the reunion, Falco and the rest of the group
work with Jean, Mikasa, and Pieck to escape the
Yeagerists in Shiganshina. While leaving, they
stop to pick up Reiner.[74] Falco then stays back
while the Warriors and Survey Corps infiltrate
the Yeagerists holed up at the Paradis docks.
As Pieck is using her Titan form to transport
Falco and the other noncombatants to a boat,
Falco sees Reiner and Annie being
overwhelmed and insists that he help them.
Pieck tries to talk him down but Falco,
feeling guilty about Galliard's death,
states that if Porco would have been in his
position, he would have leaped into the battle.
He ignores Pieck's warning and runs into the
fray. Using a nail he found at the harbor to
cut his hand, Falco transforms into his Jaw Titan
form for the first time, to Gabi's shock as she
turns around and sees a bright flash. Falco and
Pieck are able to easily decimate the remaining
Yeagerists, but as soon as they are defeated,
Falco quickly begins losing control of his Titan.
Unable to recognize his allies, Falco begins
attacking the Survey Corps members and Pieck
who tried to calm him down but to no avail
as he almost completely bites through her
Titan's nape. She is forced to hold him down
while Magath cuts him out of his Titan's nape
using a blade from the vertical maneuvering
equipment. Magath then carries Falco's unconscious
body to the boat. Afterward, Gabi and Pieck look
after an unconscious Falco resting on the boat.
Eventually, Falco awakens and is greatly dismayed
to hear that the Wall Titans have reached Marley
and have already destroyed Liberio; he later is
locked inside the infirmary with Gabi, and both
beg Annie to let them out. After leaving,
Falco and Gabi confront Annie in order to
question her about the Female Titan's ability
to easily inherit traits from other Titans.
Falco then reveals to her that he likely
received a memory of a previous Beast Titan
who was capable of flight and theorizes
that he could do the same due to the unique
appearance of his Titan which is presumably
because he ingested Zeke's spinal fluid.
Subsequently, Falco and Gabi express their intent
to leave but are reprimanded by an unwilling Annie
who expresses her concern about the possibility
of the ship sinking during Falco's transformation.
However, Kiyomi admits she is fine
with that outcome. Using his Titan,
Falco flies to Fort Salta with Gabi and Annie.
The three arrive just in time to save Mikasa,
Reiner, Jean, Connie, and Levi from being devoured
by an army of Titans. As Falco circles around to
return his passengers to Eren's Titan, Reiner
reminds Falco of his promise to keep Gabi safe.
As he gets closer to Eren, Falco is forced to
dodge projectiles launched by War Hammer Titans
generated on Eren's back. He drops Jean and Reiner
off near Eren's nape to continue the attempts to
detonate Pieck's explosives and drops Mikasa,
Annie, and Connie off near Eren's tailbone to
try to rescue Armin. After the group manages to
detonate Eren's nape, Falco collects them again
and flies them to a safe distance so that
Armin can transform atop Eren's Titan.
Returning to Fort Salta, Falco touches down
and exits his Titan to tearfully reunite
with his parents. Their reunion is short-lived,
however, as Eren transforms into a new Titan form
and continues his advance. The centipede creature
arrives at the base of the fort and begins
emitting a steam-like gas which seeps through the
fort and surrounding area; overhearing Levi demand
Mikasa and Pieck get back aboard the Jaw Titan,
Falco is horrified to learn that the gas will
soon turn all the Eldians present into mindless
Titans. Falco then departs with Pieck and the
two Ackermans. He flies Mikasa and Levi to Eren's
Titan, where the two work together to infiltrate
Eren's mouth and kill him. Following Eren's death,
Falco's Titan begins to disintegrate. Exiting his
Titan on the ground, Falco is ecstatic to see that
the Eldians have all returned to their human forms
and immediately begins searching for Gabi. The
two children's reunion is cut short by the arrival
of the Marleyans from Fort Salta, who demand that
the Eldians all prove they can no longer turn into
Titans. Before the Marleyans can execute anyone,
Armin arrives and manages to talk them down.
Thank you so much for watching this video,
it really means a lot to us, and we will see you
guys very soon in one of our next videos, bye!